[ÂM NHẠC]
>> Brian Holt: Chúng tôi sẽ để lại đệ quy sau một chút,
nói cách khác, không sử dụng đệ quy cho đến khi tôi nói với bạn rằng chúng tôi sẽ sử dụng đệ quy.
Tất cả những điều này sẽ được thực hiện bằng cách sử dụng các vòng lặp, nhưng
đệ quy là một khối xây dựng mà chúng ta cần có trong khả năng của mình
để có thể thực hiện một số vấn đề khác này.
Vì vậy, rất nhiều thuật toán đi xuống để phân loại.
Đó là bởi vì sắp xếp các số là một điều rất hữu ích trong khoa học máy tính và
có nhiều cách để lột da mèo trong trường hợp cụ thể này.
Đầu tiên chúng ta sẽ nói đến là phân loại bong bóng.
Sắp xếp bong bóng không hữu ích.
[LAUGH] Như trong bạn sẽ không bao giờ sử dụng sắp xếp bong bóng trong mã sản xuất.
Tuy nhiên, nó là một công cụ học tập rất hữu ích vì nó rất tốt
áp dụng cho cách mà chúng ta là con người nghĩ về việc sắp xếp các con số trong đầu, phải không?
Ý chính cơ bản của cửa hàng bong bóng là tôi có, hãy xem, sơ đồ ra.
>> Brian Holt: Và bút, màu đen, chúng ta bắt đầu.
Được rồi, nếu tôi có các số như 5,
tốt đấy. >> Người nói 2: Này,
Brian? >> Brian Holt: Vâng.
>> Diễn giả 2: Trước khi chúng tôi nhận được
quá xa về vấn đề này, chúng tôi vẫn có một câu hỏi về
tập thể dục. >> Brian Holt: Chắc chắn.
>> Người nói 2: Damien đang hỏi,
anh ta đang tự hỏi nếu n ít hơn hai return n hoạt động?
Anh ấy nói rằng tất cả các bài kiểm tra đều vượt qua. >> Brian Holt: n ít hơn hai,
vâng, điều đó hoàn toàn hiệu quả. >> Người nói 2: Được rồi.
>> Brian Holt: Vâng, có thể hơi
kém hiệu quả hơn nhưng bạn có một cuộc gọi bổ sung, phải không?
Vì vậy, có thể nếu ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của bạn ở 255 và nó được đẩy lên 256 và
bạn bị tràn ngăn xếp, nó có thể là một vấn đề, nhưng
nếu điều đó có ý nghĩa hơn với bạn, tôi nghĩ điều đó hoàn toàn ổn.
Có lẽ lý do tại sao tôi lại sai khi sử dụng một cái là nó rất
rõ ràng, phải không?
Rất dễ dàng cho một người nào đó đến sau, người giống như vậy, nó chỉ trả lại một cái, phải không?
Trong khi họ phải lý luận về nó,
không sao cả, nếu nó ít hơn hai thì nó sẽ trả về một, phải không?
Họ phải suy luận về điều đó.
Điều đó không khó nhưng điều đó phù hợp với bạn,
sau đó nhiều quyền lực hơn cho bạn. >> Brian Holt: Câu hỏi hay,
được rồi, vậy hãy nói về phân loại bong bóng ở đây.
Vì vậy, nếu chúng ta có một danh sách gồm 5, 7, 6, được không?
Sắp xếp bong bóng là nơi chúng ta sẽ so sánh hai số cùng một lúc và
sau đó chúng tôi sẽ hoán đổi chúng nếu chúng không đúng thứ tự.
Hãy thực sự làm điều này vì vậy 4 cũng ở đây.
Được rồi, vì vậy chúng ta sẽ có một vòng lặp bên ngoài sẽ xoay quanh các con số và
một vòng lặp bên trong sẽ so sánh những con số đó, phải không?
Vì vậy, vòng lặp bên ngoài sẽ đi qua, tôi đã giải thích điều đó không chính xác.
Vì vậy, vòng lặp bên ngoài tiếp tục chạy
miễn là có các số được hoán đổi trong lần lặp trước, phải không?
Vì vậy, vòng lặp bên ngoài sẽ luôn chạy ít nhất một lần.
Vòng lặp bên trong sẽ đi qua và
hoán đổi số nếu chúng không theo thứ tự, được không?
Vì vậy, 5 và 7, theo thứ tự, không hoán đổi.
7 và 6 không theo thứ tự, vì vậy chúng ta sẽ hoán đổi chúng.
Vì vậy, nó chỉ là 5 và sau đó chúng ta sẽ hoán đổi thành 6 và 7, phải không?
Và sau đó tại điểm 7 và 4 không theo thứ tự.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi cũng sẽ hoán đổi chúng.
Vì vậy, nó sẽ là 4, 7, phải không?
Và vào cuối lần lặp đầu tiên của chúng ta, nó sẽ là 5, 6, 4, 7, phải không?
Bây giờ một cái gì đó đã được hoán đổi trong lần lặp lại trước đó
chúng tôi sẽ làm điều đó một lần nữa.
Vì vậy, tôi sẽ xóa điều này và làm điều đó một lần nữa. >> Brian Holt: Vì vậy
Tôi nghĩ đó là 5, 6,
4, 7 cảm ơn bạn, được không?
Vì vậy, chúng tôi sẽ chạy cùng một thuật toán, 5 và 6 vẫn theo thứ tự những thuật toán đó được đưa xuống.
6 và 4, những thứ đó đã hết đơn đặt hàng o chúng tôi sẽ hoán đổi chúng.
5 hoặc 4, 6, và đó là theo thứ tự,
thứ gì đó đã được hoán đổi trong lần lặp trước.
Vì vậy, trong trường hợp cụ thể này, chúng ta sẽ làm 4, 5, 6, 7,
vì những cái đó vẫn còn thứ tự.
Bây giờ, nó theo thứ tự ngay bây giờ, phải không?
Chúng ta biết rằng nhìn vào nó, tuy nhiên, máy tính vẫn chưa biết điều đó, phải không?
Vì vậy, một cái gì đó đã hoán đổi trong lần lặp trước đó để
nó sẽ trải qua một lần nữa.
Và bởi vì không có gì sẽ hoán đổi trong lần lặp cuối cùng đó, nên [SOUND] không sao, đã xong.
Và sau đó sắp xếp bong bóng đã hoàn thành.
Vì vậy, để tóm tắt lại bạn có một vòng lặp bên ngoài.
Nó sẽ là một vòng lặp while chạy một lần, phải không?
Chạy ít nhất một lần, đó là vòng lặp do-while, phải không?
Hầu hết chúng ta không sử dụng vòng lặp do nhiều trong JavaScript.
Tôi thực sự không thể nhớ được thời gian nếu tôi đã từng làm vòng lặp một cách chuyên nghiệp
nhưng chúng tôi sẽ sử dụng nó ở đây.
Bạn cũng có thể lập mô hình đó bằng vòng lặp while, nhưng
đây là một trong những lần duy nhất bạn sử dụng vòng lặp do để bạn cũng có thể làm được.
Được rồi, bạn sẽ đến vòng lặp do-while, nơi vòng lặp bên ngoài sẽ đi
trong khi một cái gì đó đã được hoán đổi, phải không?
Và sau đó bạn có vòng lặp bên trong sẽ đi qua và nói, là x và
x, hoặc n, n và n cộng với một là chúng không theo thứ tự?
Được rồi, đổi chỗ cho nhau, phải không?
Để lại nó, và sau đó nó chỉ tiếp tục và
tiếp tục hoán đổi mọi thứ cho đến khi chúng trở lại theo thứ tự.
Bạn thấy ở đây loại biểu đồ này cho bạn thấy nó trông như thế nào theo thời gian.
Vậy Big O trên này là gì?
Chúng ta có một vòng lặp do-while bên ngoài và chúng ta có một vòng lặp for bên trong, phải không?
Vậy điều đó rốt cuộc là gì?
n bình phương, phải, vì chúng ta có một vòng lặp bên trong và một vòng lặp bên ngoài.
Và đây là một thuật toán cực kỳ kém hiệu quả nhưng
hy vọng bây giờ bạn đã hình dung chính xác cách thức hoạt động của nó.
Vì vậy, nó là một công cụ giảng dạy tốt.